I'll get you this how I met Harland
whoa that was great improv man good time
huh thanks bud hey bud Harlem's my
friends um the first time I um I haven't
heard of them but the first time I
actually physically was around him was
one of my first TV spots I did premium
blend did you host that yeah yep
you don't remember me it's fine I do I
do remember you yeah I do
cuz you were kind of not Notley didn't
say anything much to me I don't think I
said anything to anybody
wait cuz I didn't know anybody there was
all the new comics right yeah yeah yeah
you didn't know one person Wray so I was
just kind of they had all the comics on
one side of the stage why and they had
me on the other so I didn't even barely
get to shake hands with anything yeah
you didn't yeah that's why they
separated us and I was very intimidated
by you
how come guy because guy I was young I
had no money guy all right I was a broke
comedian knowing me my first TV spot
here we have a headliner been in movies
which is you yeah are you so confused I
just didn't it makes me sad that you
were intimidated by me you were you know
no need for that guy
I know but guy I know but hey guy yeah
you're just I don't I didn't know you
write write you I build up these things
in my head you know like not fantasies
but like who you who you are and the
kind of life that you live it's not
based on any kind of real thing is is
that as a young guy I'm desperate and
here's a guy that's ahead of me and you
look like you had your [ __ ] together and
I was just a little intimidated ya know
that's what I get it I've been there
yeah have you been intimidated by people
yeah who I used to open for Jim Carrey
oh really
and right around the time when Jim was
lifting off into the stratosphere and
that was whoa
intimidating it was but was was when you
open for was the on in living color or
now when I first started opening forum
yeah and then later I was opening forum
the week that Ace Ventura came out yeah
and it was it was intimidating cuz Jim's
not just that he was such a huge star at
a huge personality but he was he was
always trying stuff on you like I always
doing bit right yeah he's always you
know testing you yeah yeah and it was
weird because you felt pressured to like
you know he's trying comedy bit so I'm
not a guy that laughs if I don't think
something's funny so by whenever he
fired a blank it was awkward as hell
yeah yeah what do you worry when he did
something to make me laugh I laugh but
one eat one he didn't you wouldn't even
try to fake it no every now and then I
did but I'm not good at that yes it felt
really weird so I just it was weird but
but I love Jim and and I just so I'm
super intimidated yeah whoa because that
he blew up but did you arm cuz I've met
him yeah I find him to be very kind oh
yeah
he's a really nice guy really so gifted
yeah unbelievable so back when you open
for did you do a lot of impressions on
stage or no he had stopped at that point
I made the you know the decision to no
more impressions just stopped he wanted
to distance himself in that right so
what would you just go up and just do
like we're Chad Ryan he did a lot of
physical stuff but yeah you had like
jokes he had us at routine it was a lot
of physical stuff yeah you know he had
jokes like you know this is an
impression of me smoking a cigarette
going down the rapids and he'd just like
you know two minutes he just like
contort his body and try to light a
cigarette
oh yeah wild stuff you guys do like
clubs there's our theatres or we did we
did theatres yeah yeah I'd only imagine
and I was there for his last show the
last
time you didn't stand up he was the
weekend they spent or came out and we
did two cities we did we did Atlanta we
did Chicago and Atlanta on the the after
our show we went back to the to his
hotel room and we had the same manager
and the numbers came in for pet for pet
detective
and I think you know got really bad
reviews everyone was expect and it it
did great yeah it was like number one
right yeah and we all lit up cigars in
his room and I kind of I was kind of
there one it was really neat because I
kind of watched a guy star kind of flip
you know what I mean like I was the
living color guy yeah and then in the
next minute he was a movie star
and so we lit up cigars and then the
next day we went to Atlanta to do a show
there and that was the last time he ever
did stand-up Wow yeah it was the last
night he stopped right after I bet you
in his head he was like when he saw that
number yeah he made the decision right
then and there
oh yeah I think so right yeah like I
think I don't know that I was a movie
star but I think he kind of tells like
it's time to move on not that he hated
stand-up or but I got the impression
it's time to step into a new path and he
never said anything bad or disliked
stand-up I think he just I think he just
kind of knew it was time to go up
another staff yeah and to be there in
that moment was really kind of cool to
witness yeah would you would you ever
like to be in that step yeah we all we
all do what would you ever leave
stand-up I would never leave that I mean
I I went through some periods in my
career where I was going up some pretty
good steps and I could have left it but
I I never wanted to it was my starting
place and I always think of stand-up as
my spine and everything else that comes
off that are the ribs like voice work
and TV work and movies for me that the
spine is always the stand-up
stands without the spine sweetie nothing
stands with that sponge she's a doctor
too you know I'm saying yeah
[Music]